in other news a rideshare giant that's
lift is defending its commitment to
safety after 19 women alleged they were
sexually harassed abused or raped by
lyft drivers a lawsuit filed yesterday
says the company's response to this
sexual predator crisis amongst lyft
drivers has been appallingly inadequate
now this comes just three months after a
similar lawsuit by 14 other women Jamie
yuccas is in Los Angeles with more on
the story Jamie good morning to you what
are the allegations because it's all
very disturbing yeah good morning Gail
many women in this new lawsuit say the
incidents happened at night after they
decided to take a lift because they had
been drinking they believed they were
making a safe choice but instead ended
up fearing for their lives during the
rape I immediately frozen thought of
myself and thought to myself that the
lyft driver would kill me one by one
women came forward Wednesday detailing
alleged incidents of sexual assault I
lyft drivers the next thing I knew the
driver was on top of me trying to put
his tongue in my mouth a new lawsuit
alleges that at least as early as 2015
lyft became aware that lyft drivers were
sexually assaulting and raping female
customers and failed to adopt and
implement reasonable driver monitoring
procedures designed to protect the
safety of its passengers one alleged
victim tells CBS News she fell asleep in
her lyft and her driver assaulted her
and that's what I'll never forget it's
like my fear and like you know having to
like make that sudden decision like how
am I gonna give myself out of this
in a statement lyft says what these
women described is something no one
should ever have to endure we recognize
these risks which is why we are
relentless in our work to build safety
into every aspect of our work the
company says it has launched more than
15 new safety features including daily
background checks for all drivers and in
app emergency assistance for passengers
but lawyers allege eight of the
plaintiffs in the latest lawsuit were
assaulted since those measures were
implemented what lyft has to do
they have to make all rides digitally
recorded if an employee knows that their
employers watching them they're not
going to be committing crimes in the car
the women are suing for unspecified
damages as for lyft it says it's
partnering with the nation's largest
anti-sexual violence organization called
rain as part of a sexual violence
prevention education program Anthony
Jamie thank you